les soeurs barroso sont venus rendre
visite à leur mère anna 91 ans qui vit
dans ce ch et celle des de montréal les
filles ont appris hier qu'elle avait
contracté la coved 19
nous on devait peut-être dans ceux qui
avaient le droit de visiter les parents
aujourd'hui parce que c'est à partir
d'aujourd'hui
mais puisque ma mère est atteinte du coc
vide
on nous a dit qu'elle serait déplacé au
sous-sol et qu'on pourrait pas l'avoir
puis hier on a pleuré chacun dans nos
maisons aujourd'hui on est réuni on peut
posture peut pas se prendre mes yeux de
l'amour puis moi aujourd'hui je vibre
avant la pandémie les soeurs venaient
chaque jour aidé leur mère à manger et à
faire sa toilette
c'est la première fois qu'elle se voit
en moi j'ai pas de mots pour expliquer à
quel point heureuse d'avoir partagé ce
moment avec mes soeurs puis de pouvoir
être là avec ma mère les personnes les
plus compétentes pour s'occuper de leurs
proches c'est les nerfs naturel de
penser qu'en retirant les familles du
quotidien des personnes âgées puisque
sahara est tenu le coup c'était
illusoire
cette gériatre soutient que les projets
d'un apporte une contribution vitale au
réseau de la santé et que leur retrait a
contribué à la propagation du virus
on a plutôt exposer les personnes âgées
à plus de personnes il passait sa peau
n'est plus qu'une personne pour
remplacer la prochaine un spa surprenant
c'est pas assez
maintenant québec envoie en renfort ces
prochaines inconnu des établissements
mais pose des conditions
quand on y danse un chsct ou est-ce
qu'une éclosion
le projet d'un ne pourra pas y entrer au
moins depuis quelques jours même une
semaine les établissements donne des
nouvelles de façon beaucoup plus
régulière ça prenait des ressources pour
le faire mais le message est entendu ce
qu'une obligation et les prochaines
heures au moins des nouvelles plus
régulièrement
mais c'est sûr que pour ceux qui ne
pourront pas y aller la situation reste
vraiment préoccupant
parce que les proches font bien plus que
prodiguer des soins ici sébastien
desrosiers radio-canada mourir